bitter cold is descending on us here in
europe
the sudden arrival of wintry weather
could spell disaster for a region
already in the midst of an energy crisis
and if we're a little bit unlucky this
winter it could turn into a crisis
because and this is the real real
problem i find is
we are at the mercy of the weather now i
think we are going to be walking into a
recession uh because there won't be
enough energy to be had whatever you
want to call it a crisis a crunch a
shortage what's been unfolding across
global energy markets this year is
impacting all of our lives
energy prices have soared with benchmark
european natural gas prices jumping
almost 400 percent
even prices for coal which is being
shunned by many countries have almost
doubled
that means in almost every corner of the
world the energy needed to heat our
homes or fuel our cars or power our
businesses has become drastically more
expensive
this has been described as the first
energy crisis of the green transition
and it's true that looming behind every
aspect of this energy shortage is
climate change but there are so many
different causes for this year's energy
crisis
at least 15 according to one list that
an expert sent me
[Music]
we won't get into all of them but we
will look at some of the most
significant factors behind the crunch
and what they tell us about the future
of energy as the green transition gains
speed
that's all coming up on business beyond
the simplest answer for this year's
energy crisis is the pandemic
the first months of the coven 19
pandemic led many economies to shut down
demand for energy plunged as businesses
close people stayed home and planes were
grounded around the world
and so fossil fuel producers responded
they stopped drilling for oil cut back
on natural gas production and even
closed coal mines
this year economies have roared back to
life and the speed of that recovery has
caught pretty much the entire world off
guard and we're not just talking about
energy suppliers
you probably have heard of the global
supply chain crisis or the semiconductor
shortage
all of these have a common cause the
unexpected bounce back in demand
that is good news in a way in the sense
that as the economy has been picking up
again after the kobe 19 crisis
we've seen
uh higher energy demand from various
economic sectors it's all part of the
globally disrupted supply chains from
computer chips to containers to gas
because
yes hopefully we'll be coming out of
this covered pandemic at some point the
long-term fallout that we really didn't
think about when we're all in lockdown
it's like
how to sort everything out again
but the timing of this year's energy
crisis is a bit ironic
because the shortage of fossil fuels to
power our economies comes as many
countries are making plans to abandon
them once and for all
[Music]
we are on course
to achieve our goal our target of 100
use
of clean energy by 2030
we are in fact
closer than we have
ever been before
to avoiding
climate chaos
despite all of these big pronouncements
and pledges to become greener the
pandemic has shown us a bitter reality
the world is still very much dependent
on fossil fuels
even here in germany which has a
reputation as a climate leader we still
got most of our energy from
non-renewable sources in the first half
of this year
on a global scale that energy balance
skews drastically more towards fossil
fuels
the underlying issue is demand is just
it takes a long time for demand to
switch away from fossil fuels in 1981 um
oil gas and coal account for 84 percent
of total energy demand last year that
share was still 84
the first place where we really started
to see energy shortages unfold this year
was in china china's economy was the
first to bounce back from the pandemic
thanks to demand for its goods from
abroad
its factories went into overdrive
requiring huge amounts of fuel
for china that largely means coal which
still accounts for 70 percent of its
electricity generation
but a number of factors from a de facto
ban on australian coal to strict
electricity pricing meant that supply
didn't keep up
by september china was in the throes of
an energy crisis the government ordered
factories to close and told coal mines
to increase production
the blackouts and power cuts to key
industries have had a serious impact on
china's economy
and it's basically led beijing to double
down on coal
many fear that that will jeopardize
china's climate goals
with the coal shortage at home
china turned to international natural
gas markets to help keep the lights on
and factories running
that huge amount of demand coming from
china rippled across global energy
markets including to those here in
europe
china's becoming a major force in the
natural gas market as it works to wean
its economy off of even more polluting
coal
each year millions of households swap
coal power for gas
it's a launderable program that it's an
anti-pollution program so they're moving
their coastal households from burning
coal to using acid and to reduce
pollution it's great and it works um you
know china's big cities 10 years ago
were the most polluted cities in the
world and now they're not anymore um so
bad but they're not the worst
china's demand for natural gas both
during this year's crisis and in recent
years has put the squeeze on europe
the european union gets most of its
natural gas from russia but norway
algeria and qatar are also big suppliers
brussels has made diversifying its
supply of natural gas a priority
and it's turned to liquefied natural gas
or lng which is sent via tankers like
these instead of pipelines
in 2019 so pre-pandemic lng accounted
for about 22 of the eu's natural gas
consumption that was a new record
competition between china and europe for
lng has been building but this year's
energy shortages led to an all-out
bidding war and europe has been losing
the population figures are
just eye-watering so um when it gets
cold there they suck up the lng market
and then
you know europe uh have a bit less but
then i mean there's pipeline supply here
norway algeria russia
they can supply us with gas as well but
that's where in europe there's another
problem at the moment um
actually lots of them
the biggest of those problems for the eu
is russia
western europe began importing natural
gas from russia or more accurately the
soviet union in the 1960s
there are now several pipelines that
connect the siberian gas fields of
russia's gazprom to various storage
sites across the eu
the eu's dependence on russian gas has
long worried many within the block
when you build a pipeline you build a
relationship and potentially there's
leverage
both ways by the supplier by the buyer
and so security has been a standing
issue in the natural gas trade and those
concerns have become very real this year
as the eu faces a natural gas shortage
while some countries like belgium and
france have gas storage levels around 80
percent
storage tanks in other countries like
austria are sitting almost half empty
after last year's cold winter depleted
stockpiles
making matters worse russia has been
slow to send additional gas to europe
this year despite the critical shortage
of stocks
there is a credible signs that russia
itself is struggling to meet all of the
gas demand
uh
now first of all they had to fill up
their own inventories uh ahead of
the winter and in russia as we all know
it gets really cold so they they can't
leave their own people in the cold and
sell it all to
plushie western europe
but some analysts believe the limited
deliveries are no coincidence and accuse
moscow of exploiting europe's energy
weakness
part of the slowdown in imports of the
us from russia or against exports from
russia to us is malicious
enter nordstrom 2 the 9.5 billion euro
pipeline russia has recently completed
constructing from the russian port ust
luga to griveswal
germany it will double russian gas
supply to germany
but it first must be approved by german
regulators and that's not a given for a
pipeline that has been embroiled in
controversy from the start
critics have found a lot of reasons to
hate nordstrom 2. they fear how it will
make the eu even more dependent on
russian gas
and they worry about how it will bypass
ukraine where much of russia's gas to
europe now flows through and that brings
in billions of euros to kiev every year
some believe russia is withholding gas
exports as a way to blackmail the eu
into approving the pipeline
whether russia is weaponizing its gas
exports or not north stream 2 is crucial
to russia's economic future here in
europe keep in mind about 40 percent of
russia's government revenues come from
oil and gas exports every year the
russians have
spent a fortune
under putin developing an entire new
natural gas province and as a result of
which the russians are positioned for
the next generation of gas supply to
europe
well
what happens if europe then as part of
its
climate policy
cuts back on natural gas consumption
what's what becomes of that investment
then and it's not just russia that's
confronting a future where its biggest
export is no longer needed
so is the group of oil producers that
along with russia is known as opec plus
the cartel has resisted increasing oil
production despite rising prices
opec has blamed uncertainty about demand
and the pandemic but some see a deeper
message and its refusal to bend to these
demands
we can't have uh consumer governments
telling producer governments that
we don't need oil and gas which is
absolutely the crux of their livelihood
that's where the livelihood comes from
then those countries have every right to
allow prices to go up now so that they
can rebuild their um
coffers to rebuild their budget deficits
and just have surpluses so that when
there is energy transition and their uh
oil and gas
products effectively are out of demand
they have a buffer that they can
help diversify their economy in other
words fossil fuel producers may be
motivated to try and make money while
they still can
for moscow its current gambit to secure
the future of nordstrom 2 doesn't appear
to be working
in november german regulator suspended
the approval process for the pipeline
citing issues with the parent company's
business registration
that doesn't necessarily mean the end of
nordstrom 2
but it is a delay that could set the
project back by several months
raising the risk of serious energy
shortages here in europe this winter if
it gets cold for long across northwest
europe or northeast asia there will be
there's a high risk of real power and
heating outages just as coveted surges
again and then you'll have people
sitting at home cold and sick
like i touched on earlier some see green
policies at fault for this current
crisis
they say that overly ambitious targets
to reduce emissions have made fossil
fuels paria's before renewables were
fully ready to take up the load
and indeed investment in oil and gas has
more than halved since 2014.
the challenge is fossil fuel investment
is falling very very quickly
but for the world to keep meeting rising
energy demand
investment in renewables needs to go up
by four times you're talking about like
hundred trillion dollars that money is
just not there and it won't be there uh
that volume of money so you're
essentially talking about energy poverty
versus green energy and countries like
china and india will simply not choose
energy poverty but others are more
optimistic that renewables could soon
replace fossil fuels i think that
that this situation exposes not so much
the fact that we have tried to uh
decarbonize you know
faster than than wise this is something
that sometimes you hear from from the
false security industry it's not that at
all frankly it's rather the opposite if
we had a larger share of renewables at
this stage then it would mean we would
be less reliant on fossil fuels less
reliant on
the energy source whose fight this price
is currently very high because of
increased competition
after all wind and sun are essentially
limitless resources as energy sources
they can insulate countries from
geopoliticking our reliance on fossil
fuels such as natural gas has shown us
that it can end up in in very high
prices we need to transition away from
that into a system of
[Music]
natural resources that are renewable and
whose cost is virtually zero
many politicians are seizing this crisis
as a chance to push for more investment
and renewables
but building out that infrastructure
could take years
so what about right now
for now governments seem to have decided
the answer is more fossil fuels
china as we saw earlier has renewed its
commitment to coal
and here in the eu where many countries
have pledged to give up coal in the
coming decade idle coal plants are being
put back online
in the united states the white house has
announced it will top its strategic
reserve of oil to help bring down
gasoline prices for consumers
this many analysts point out is not the
best way to get consumers to give up oil
or gas the reality is if supplies are
coming down much much faster and demand
hasn't moved high prices is the only
solution because only then will you
actually get consumers to move away the
fact is that
if you put a price on fossil keywords
without there being a clean alternative
that consumers can shift to and that is
also affordable then behavior change is
made more difficult and consumers are
going to be left frustrated and that's
where many people are finding themselves
now
frustrated furious at risk of not being
able to cover their own energy needs
so what are we to take away from all of
this
for me in another hour i will start the
engine on my car and i will know why i'm
dependent on fossil fuels
and so on
um
in the in the words of a famous cartoon
of years ago
we have met the enemy
and he is us
for all of the excitement around the
green transition fossil fuels still
power our lives and until that changes
fossil fuels and the countries that
produce them will continue to determine
how much it costs to keep the lights on
and that's it for this episode of
business beyond if you like this video
check out our playlist
and see you next time
[Music]